pensez à quelqu'un que vous avez croisé
aujourd'hui votre chéri un ami ou un
collègue un voisin un peu importe
qu'est-ce qui vous prouve que cette
personne à laquelle vous pensez possède
une conscience alors bien sûr les êtres
humains qu'on croise tous les jours on
l'air conscients ils sont éveillés ils
s'expriment ils réagissent quand on leur
parle mais ce qu'on appelle la
conscience c'est un peu plus que ça du
matin au soir dans nos têtes se joue un
film intérieur on a dépensé des
sensations des émotions
on ressent des choses on vit ce qu'on
appelle une expérience subjective et
qu'est-ce qui me prouve que les gens que
je croise tous les jours
eux aussi vivent ça à l'intérieur la
conscience a beau être le phénomène le
plus immédiat auquel on soient exposés
quotidiennement et a pas de consensus
clair sur ce qu'elle est vraiment on ne
comprend ni pourquoi ni comment elles
existent pour certains la conscience
juste une illusion et pour d'autres il
s'agit carrément du plus grands mystères
de l'univers
pour expliquer l'existence de cette
conscience subjective on peut faire
appel à la science mais on va voir que
c'est aussi un problème qui est
largement philosophique et qui nous
renvoie à des questions sur la nature
profonde de ce que nous sommes et du
monde qui nous entoure pour vous en
parler aujourd'hui j'ai donc décidé de
faire équipe avec un philosophe un vrai
j'ai nommé thibault de la chaîne
monsieur fille alors thibault qui es-tu
et qu'est ce qu'on trouve sur tâche elle
bonjour david et merci pour l'invitation
je suis prof de philo et logicien et sur
ma chienne on aborde tous les champs de
la philosophie et contrairement à l'idée
qu'on s'en fait parfois je pense que la
philosophie est plutôt proche des
sciences en ceci qu'elle partage les
mêmes ambitions de connaissance et de
compréhension du monde par des moyens
rationnelle et en particulier sur un
sujet comme la conscience il me semble
très bénéfique de faire travailler
ensemble les sciences et la philosophie
ok mais avant qu'on attaque rassure-moi
tam bien eu conscience toi alors les
soins vérifiés c'est bon j'ai une
conscience
[Musique]
notre conscience notre vie mentale
intérieur est riche de tout un tas de
phénomène des perceptions sensorielles
comme par exemple des sons des odeurs ou
des couleurs mais aussi des sensations
intérieur comme des douleurs ou des
démangeaisons dans notre flux de
conscience on trouve aussi des émotions
comme la colère ou la joie et dépenser
plus ou moins complexes qui ont toutes
un ressenti particulier spécifique
si par exemple là je pense à un plat de
spaghettis ça provoque pas en moi la
même expérience intérieure que si je
pense à une grosses araignées velues ou
à jennifer lawrence
tous ces phénomènes manteau qu'on
expérimente en permanence un semble en
apparence très différent des phénomènes
physiques qui agitent le monde qui nous
entoure le monde physique ce sont des
objets qui se déplacent les particules
qui interagissent des réactions
chimiques qui se déroulent et à première
vue on voit pas très bien comment
expliquer notre expérience consciente
notre vie intérieure avec toute la
richesse qu'elle contient juste avec des
particules et des réactions chimiques
qui s'enchaînent notre conscience et le
monde physique semble deux choses
totalement différentes mais est-ce qu'on
peut aller au delà des apparences qu'est
ce qui nous fait dire que les phénomènes
manteau serait à part et bien suppose
que je te dise que j'ai une douleur très
vive au bras qu'est-ce que tu ferais
pour étudier ce phénomène
j'examinerai tombera pour voir s'il ya
des bleus ou des blessures
peut-être je ferai passer une radio pour
voir s'il est pas cassé mais ce que tu
verrais sur mon bras ou sur la radio est
ce que ce serait vraiment ma douleur tu
verra peut-être une fracture et tu
supposera que cette fracture cause ma
douleur mais la fracture est un
phénomène physique réel et en soit tout
à fait distincte de ma douleur qui est
un phénomène mentale savoir s'il ya une
fracture cela n'a rien d'immédiat et
surtout l'erreur est possible même si je
voyais mon bras tordu et sanglant cela
pourrait être du maquillage ou une
illusion d'optique ou bien de mes os
pourrait être en fait en caoutchouc
s'est pas absolument impossible ce
serait juste surprenant ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'il ya un sens à distinguer
entre croire avoir une fracture et avoir
réellement une fracture entre
l'apparence et la réalité de la fracture
maintenant suppose que tu m'as fait
passer tous les tests médicaux possibles
et que tu n'a vu aucune fracture ni
aucune anomalie à quelque niveau que ce
soit pour et tu finir par me dire écoute
je pense que tu fais erreur sur ta
douleur on a bien regardé tombera il a
rien donc tu crois avoir mal en fait
t'as pas mal banon quand on a mal on a
mal on sait tout de suite on peut pas se
tromper sur le fait qu'on a mal en effet
autrement dit il n'y a pas de sens à
distinguer entre l'apparence de la douze
et sa réalité l'apparence de la douleur
et la douleur croire avoir mal c'est
avoir mal et en cela c'est un état très
différent d'un état physique comme une
fracture
la connaissance d'un état physique n'est
jamais immédiate et elle reste toujours
faillible tandis qu'il y a quelque chose
d'immédiat et d'un sa bible dans la
connaissance que j'ai de mes propres
états mentaux
ce qui est paradoxal c'est que si je
suis certain mois de ressentir une
douleur en fait je suis le seul à
pouvoir le savoir avec certitude c'est
un truc totalement personnelle alors
qu'un événement physique comme le fait
qu'ils aient une fracture bas ça on peut
le savoir tous les deux en regardant par
exemple la radio ou bien mon bras
c'est vrai nous vivons tous dans le même
monde physique mais la conscience que
nous en avons est une expérience
absolument individuelle et
incommunicable cette connaissance
immédiate et infaillible que j'ai de mes
propres états mentaux
elle est condamnée à rester privées
j'aurai beau hurler de douleur on te
montre en nombre à margut ça ne te feras
pas connaître ma douleur tu pourrais
essayer de l'imaginer tu pourras aller
jusqu'à te casser toi même le bras par
curiosité ou c'est un peu extrême là
quand même
mais surtout c'est inutile car ce ne
sera jamais que ta douleur que tu
connaîtras et non la mienne pour
connaître vraiment ma douleur il
faudrait en quelque sorte en faire
l'expérience à ma place il faudrait être
moi en cela les états mentaux sont
subjectifs c'est à dire qu'il se
rattache à un sujet un mois cette
différence entre un mois et le reste du
monde est centrale pour comprendre ce
qu'est la conscience est ce que sont les
états mentaux
bon donc c'est clair un les phénomènes
manteau ou un certain nombre de
propriétés qui les distinguent
singulièrement des phénomènes physiques
d'ailleurs ça se voit bien à la manière
dont on les décrit les phénomènes
manteau ils sont subjectifs privé et du
coup on les décrit en utilisant la
première personne je ressens ceci alors
que les phénomènes physiques
c'est tout le contraire il son objectif
public tout le monde peut les observer
et on les décrit en utilisant la
troisième personne
il se passe cela ça pourrait ne pas
poser de problème particulier d'avoir
d'un côté des phénomènes physiques et de
l'autre des phénomènes mentaux qui
serait très différent mais ce qui est
étrange c'est que manifestement ce ne
sont pas deux mondes qui s'ignorent un
les phénomènes manteau semble intimement
liée à certains phénomènes physiques
par exemple on a tous cette idée
intuitif que notre conscience serait
localisé dans notre cerveau et même si
on n'a jamais vu détecter directement la
conscience et qu'on voit pas très bien
d'ailleurs comment elle pourrait sortir
de ce tas de matières flasque et humide
con
la tête on voit bien qu'un certain
nombre de nos états de conscience sont
corrélés à des états cérébraux ont déjà
première chose on est conscient quand
notre cerveau est en état d'éveil ce qui
est un truc qu'on peut caractériser de
façon physique un objectif on n'est
jamais conscients que notre cerveau est
en état de sommeil profond
donc ça montre bien qu'il ya un lien
entre la conscience et le substrat
cérébrale et puis on sait que la
conscience elle cerveau ont de multiples
interactions réciproques
si je prends de l'aspirine par exemple
ça va calmer ma douleur si je bois de
l'alcool bas mon flux de conscience va
être légèrement perturbé et donc le
physique agit sur le mental et le lien
de cause à effet ça me pouvoir se
produire aussi dans l'autre sens si je
veux lever mon bras si je décide de
lever mon bras et cette volonté elle me
semble mental et pourtant à la fin mon
bras se lèvent physiquement et
d'ailleurs grâce aux différentes
techniques d'imagerie cérébrale comme
par exemple irm fonctionnelle
on sait de mieux en mieux faire le lien
entre certains états de conscience et
l'activation de zones de notre cerveau
en résumé la situation est la suivante
notre conscience nos états mentaux
semble avoir des caractéristiques très
différentes du monde physique
et pourtant ces états sont
irrémédiablement corrélés à des états
cérébraux qui sont donc que physique
cette constatation forme ce que les
philosophes appellent le problème du
corps et de l'esprit et le premier a
vraiment posé les bases d'une théorie
pour essayer d'expliquer ça a été des
cartes des cartes a présenté un argument
historiquement très important dans ses
méditations métaphysiques son point de
départ c'est cette infaillibilité du
mental dont on a déjà parlé il n'y a pas
d'erreur possible sur mes propres états
mentaux et encore moins sur le fait que
j'aie des états mentaux
c'est à dire que j'ai une pensée j'ai un
esprit par contre il n'est pas
impossible que je me trompe entièrement
sur le monde physique tout ça pourrait
n'être qu'une vaste illusion que je me
construis moi même comme dans un rêve
même si c'est très improbable
conclusions qu'en tirent des cartes
puisqu'il est possible de douter de
l'ain mais absolument pas de l'autre
c'est donc que le physique et le mental
le corps et l'âme ce sont deux choses
distinctes
c'est cette thèse de distinction de
l'âme et du corps qu'on appelle dualisme
cartésien dit comme ça le dualisme
cartésien ça me semble assez naturel non
je pense que si on interroge les gens
dans la rue spontanément la plupart sont
d'accord pour dire que le monde physique
existe mais qu'ils ont aussi une âme un
esprit un truc en plus qui leur permet
d'agir sur leur corps et qui avec un peu
de chance va même survivre alors
physique d'ailleurs on voit bien que
toutes les grandes religions sont plus
ou moins implicitement dualiste donc le
dualisme à la d carte ça a l'air d'être
une explication plutôt satisfaisante au
problème de la conscience sauf qu'en
fait elle n'est pas très populaire chez
les gens qui ont un peu réfléchi au
problème
qu'il s'agisse des scientifiques ou des
philosophes et oui car si le dualisme
explique bien les spécificités du mental
par rapport au physique
par contre ils peinent à rendre compte
des interactions entre mentale et
physique comme tu l'as déjà dit l'esprit
semble agir sur le corps et
réciproquement
mais comment l'expliquer dans un cadre
dualiste alors pour des cartes le point
d'interaction entre l'âme et le corps
n'était une petite partie du cerveau la
glande pinéale pourquoi là et vient
parce que c'était en plein milieu du
cerveau qu'on savait pas à conserver
alors maintenant on sait à quoi sert il
s'agit d'une glande endocrine dont qui
sert à la sécrétion hormonale et y
produit notamment de la mélatonine qui a
impliqué dans les rythmes biologiques
comme par exemple l'alternance de la
veille et du sommeil ont donc des cartes
se plantait sur la glande pinéale mais
de toute façon ou que vous logiez l'âme
le même problème se pose si les
interactions entre l'âme et le corps
sont des interactions causale cela
voudrait dire que lorsque ma volonté
fait se lever mon bras cet événement
physique n'a pas été initiée par une
cause physique
ce serait donc littéralement surnaturel
arrivé à bouger son bras par la pensée
serait de l'ordre du miracle et par
conséquent aujourd'hui la plupart des
philosophes de l'esprit rejette le
dualisme et lui préfère une autre thèse
qu'on appelle le physique alisme ou
parfois le matérialisme la définition du
physique alisme consiste à affirmer
qu'il n'existe rien d'autre que le monde
physique
tout n'est que matière particules mais
il n'existe pas de substances
supplémentaires tels que l'âme l'esprit
ou je ne sais quoi d'autre cette thèse
du physique alice mêle veut paraître
aussi assez naturel d'ailleurs aller
complètement en accord avec la manière
dont on fait traditionnellement de la
science en physique ou en chimie la moue
l'esprit rentre pas dans les équations
ils font pas partie des choses qu'on
prend en compte pour essayer d'expliquer
le déroulement des phénomènes mais si on
accepte cette thèse du physique alice
mais il va falloir expliquer comment la
conscience peut exister
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a des états
mentaux une vie intérieure subjective
alors qu'on est juste un tas de matière
et que d'autres tas de matières comme
les cailloux a priori en ont pas une
première variante du physique alisme
pour essayer de répondre à cette
question
c'est la théorie de l'identité esprit
cerveau c'est une théorie radical qui
dit que l'esprit n'est rien d'autre que
le cerveau et que tout phénomène qu'on
qualifie de mental est en fait
simplement
un phénomène cérébrale et donc physique
on peut prendre une analogie avec
l'existence de la vie pendant longtemps
on a pensé que la vie était quelque
chose de particulier de fondamentalement
différent de la matière inerte
certains ont même imaginé qu'il puisse y
avoir une sorte de fluide vital qui
distinguerait les créatures vivantes des
corps inanimés
et c'était justement le mot âme plus
précisément psic et en grec et anima en
latin qu'ont utilisé pour désigner ce
principe qui anime les êtres vivants le
vivant c'est l'animé c'est à dire ce qui
est doué d'une âme ainsi distingué de
l'inerte willam à d'abord été une notion
biologique qui ne renvoyait pas
spécialement à la pensée vont attribuer
par exemple aux végétaux une nam nam
végétative qui les fait croître et sans
pour autant leur attribuer une pensée
mais bon on sait aujourd'hui que la vie
n'a rien de fondamentalement mystérieux
c'est juste de la chimie très
sophistiqué un organisme vivant n'est
rien de plus qu'un tas de molécules très
complexe qui interagissent et même si
les propriétés des êtres vivants ont
l'air très différente de celle des
cailloux elles se réduisent en
définitive a des propriétés physiques et
chimiques
en somme pas besoin d'armes pour
expliquer le vivant un organisme c'est
juste une machine physico chimiques très
complexe et très bien réglée l'un des
premiers défenseurs de cette idée c'est
justement des cartes c'est le sens de sa
fameuse thèse des animaux machine et
c'est donc seulement à la suite de
descartes que le mot ham va se mettre à
renvoyer uniquement à l'esprit l'âme qui
pensent et non plus l'âme qui anime pour
les tenants de l'identité esprit cerveau
l'origine de la conscience serait en
quelque sorte de la même nature mais un
niveau au dessus
la conscience ne serait rien de plus que
la résultante de phénomènes biologiques
dont on n'a pas encore élucidées tous
les ressorts mais sans qu'ils aient
besoin de faire intervenir quoi que ce
soit d'autre
mais cette thèse comporte malgré tout
quelques difficultés si on imagine par
exemple que la sensation de douleur au
dos correspondent à un certain état
cérébral
ça paraît assez peu crédible que deux
personnes qui est toutes les deux mal au
dos soit exactement dans le même état
cérébral et si la conscience est une
résultante de la biologie telle qu'on la
connaît ça voudrait dire que des formes
de vie alternatifs par exemple le
extraterrestres pour être pas avoir de
conscience on sent bien que cette vision
de la conscience comme réductible
simplement à des phénomènes be
logique est assez limitative de même
qu'on arrive à imaginer que des formes
de vie puisse exister sans faire appel
exactement au même substrat chimiques
que nous par exemple l'adn ou les
protéines
on devrait pouvoir imaginer des formes
de conscience associés et c'est ce qui a
poussé les philosophes a développé une
variante de la preuve physique à liste
de l'esprit
[Musique]
alors timo cette variante du physique
alisme pour l'expliquer je vais faire un
petit détour
cette machine à une propriété très
intéressante quand tu lui donnes des
nombres entiers en entrée il en ressort
la somme de ces nombres oui bah c'est
juste un additionnel
une machine qui additionnent c'est
incroyable et on pourrait se demander
mais qu'est ce que l'addition est ce
qu'il y a une âme additionnant tu dans
cette machine mais bien sûr que non
c'est juste un processus mécanique
physique et un système de cross mais je
suppose que tu ne peux pas dire que
l'addition c'est précisément ce
processus physique à base de cross sans
quoi ça voudrait dire que les
calculatrices moderne qui ne fonctionne
pas avec des crosses bien en fait elles
ne sont pas capables d'additionner
maintenant pour avoir une addition il
faut prendre des nombres en entrée puis
filer un nombre sortie qui soit la somme
mais peu importe la machine qu'elle soit
mécanique électronique on s'en fout hein
en fait il faut juste qu'elles réalisent
la bonne fonction exactement l'addition
est une fonction qui peut être réalisé
de toutes sortes de façons on peut même
construire un additionnel dans le
démineur de windows pourquoi pas et ce
qui est vrai d'une fonction toute simple
comme l'addition peut être tenu pour
vrai plus généralement de toute fonction
c'est ce qu'on appelle la thèse de la
réalisa militer multiples toute fonction
en gros tout mécanisme qui transforme
des entrées en sortie peut être
implémenté de diverses façons dans des
systèmes de nature très différente
maintenant passons des machines qui
additionnent aux machines qu'ils pensent
si l'on est physique à liszt on doit
croire que la pensée est le fruit d'un
processus physiques qui se produit dans
l'organisme de la même façon que
l'addition est le fruit d'un processus
physiques qui se produit dans la
calculatrice
or on a vu que l'addition ne réside pas
dans le processus physiques particuliers
qui a lieu dans la machine mais dans la
fonction que celui ci réalise et la
thèse qu'on peut défendre alors c'est
qu'il en est de même pour la pensée la
pensée n'est pas le processus biologique
particulier qui se déroule dans notre
cerveau mais c'est la fonction que
réalise ce processus c'est cette thèse
qu'on appelle en philosophie l'esprit le
fonctionnalisme la pensée et la fonction
réalise et biologiquement dans notre
organisme qui transforme en gros des
entrées sensorielles en comportement en
fait pour le fonctionnalisme on a une
conscience parce qu'on est une machine à
traiter l'information suffisamment
sophistiqué notre système nerveux prend
en entrée nos perceptions et y donnant
sorti nos actions physiques
un objet s nos paroles en somme ma
pensée est bien lié à des mécanismes
biologiques mais l'erreur des partisans
de l'identité esprit cerveau était de
croire qu'elle était essentiellement lié
à ces mécanismes de la même façon que
l'addition serait essentiellement liés
au mécanisme de crasse de la dia tort ma
pensée est plutôt une fonction réalisé
en l'occurrence dans la biologie mais
qui pourrait tout à fait l'être dans
d'autres types de systèmes par exemple
dans une biologie extraterrestre très
différente ou même simplement dans un
ordinateur
d'après le fonctionnalisme si j'ai un
programme informatique qui implémentent
la même fonction les mêmes relations
entre les entrées et les sorties qu'un
cerveau humain mars programme
informatique
il aura une conscience eh bien oui le
fonctionnaliste aura toutes les raisons
de le croire est d'ailleurs peut-être
que comparé à ces intelligences
artificielles notre réalisation
biologique de la pensée aura quelque
chose d'aussi rudimentaire que la
réalisation mécanique de l'addition dans
la dia tort ça veut dire qu'il faudra
peut-être un jour considéré certains
programmes informatiques comme des êtres
conscients à part entière et qu on
risquera en débranchant son ordinateur
de tuer une intelligence artificielle
est-ce qu'il faudra interdire la cruauté
envers les ja de la même manière qu'on
condamne la cruauté envers les animaux
une autre application perturbante de la
proche fonctionnaliste c'est qu'il
n'existe aucune différence entre un
phénomène mental et sa simulation
informatique et donc on pourrait très
bien être nous mêmes que des simulations
informatiques
une conséquence au moins aussi étrange
du fonctionnalisme tient à la
possibilité de réaliser la fonction du
cerveau à une échelle macroscopique
nous avons 100 milliards de neurones
figurez-vous maintenant imaginez qu'on
réunisse 100 milliards d'êtres humains
ça peut sembler énorme fête en mettant
juste un être humain par mètre carré ça
tiendrait en corée du sud et supposer
qu'on fasse agir c'est 100 milliards
d'êtres humains les uns avec les autres
de la même façon que des neurones par
exemple chacun serait muni d'un appareil
qui permet de recevoir un signal et d'en
émettre à d'autres de la même façon que
des neurones peuvent être activés par
d'autres neurones et transmettre cette
activation à d'autres ce système formé
de 100 milliards d'êtres humains
réaliserez à une autre échelle
exactement la même fonction que mon
cerveau maintenant mais dira-t-on que ce
système a une pensée qu'il a une
véritable conscience semblable voire
identiques à ma conscience et aussi
comme il est possible de simuler un
transistor électrique avec juste de
l'eau et puis un système de vannes de
pompes et de bassines on pourrait
imaginer un système hydraulique
gigantesque qui reproduirait le
fonctionnement d'un ordinateur simulant
une con
science et du coup un énorme ensemble de
bassines et de pompes serait conscient
comme toi et bien fonctionnaliste
devrait répondre au oui qu'importe la
machine pourvu qu'on ait la fonction
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le fonctionnalisme a plutôt
la cote chez les philosophes de l'esprit
et pourtant pour certains cette approche
échouent à prendre en compte quelques
aspects fondamentaux de la conscience
faisons l'expérience de pensée suivante
imaginez que dans ma tête le spectre des
couleurs soit inversée par rapport aux
autres c'est à dire que quand dans votre
tête vous voyez ça eh bien moi je vois
ça est depuis toujours un
alors évidemment quand on discute on est
d'accord sur les mots on affirme tous
les deux que les tomates sont rouges et
que les salades sont vertes mais du coup
moi ce que j'appelle rouge c'est cette
sensation là et vers cette sensation là
ça pourrait très bien que le canon et
comment on ferait pour s'en rendre
compte
même en sachant tout de la biologie de
la perception des couleurs je ne
pourrais pas savoir une telle chose je
sais les faits que ça me fait de voir du
rouge mais je ne peux pas savoir l'effet
que ça te fait à toi mais vont inclure
et comme on est quand même très
semblables biologiquement jeu pourrait
supposer que c'est similaire
les choses deviennent plus piquante
lorsqu'on considère une espèce
biologique très différentes
le philosophe thomas synaeghel dans un
article fameux prenez l'exemple de la
chauve souris
les chauves souris se repère par
écholocation c'est à dire qu'elles ont
une sorte de sonar biologique qui leur
permet de se représenter l'espace autour
d'elle là pour le coup on sait très bien
ce qui se passe physiquement
l'écholocalisation des chauves-souris
utilise des ultrasons dont on comprend
parfaitement la propagation
vu de l'extérieur il ya aucun problème
mais comprendre le fonctionnement de cet
organe nous permet-il vraiment de
comprendre qu'est ce que ça fait de
percevoir l'espace à travers lui quelle
expérience du monde cet organe
donne-t-il aux chauves souris
je ne peux imaginer d'expérience
consciente que par analogie avec mes
propres expériences consciente
or je n'ai pas de sonars et je n'ai
absolument rien qui ressemble
il y aurait dans la connaissance du
monde qu'à la chauve-souris quelque
chose qui m'échappe
absolument l'effet que ça fait d'être
une chauve souris je ne sais pas et ne
peut pas savoir l'effet que ça fait
d'être une chauve-souris cet effet que
ça fait absolument subjectif
incommunicable privé irréductible à la
connaissance du monde physique et qui
semble pourtant constituer une certaine
forme de connaissance
les philosophes les désigne aujourd'hui
par le mot qualia est la grande question
est de savoir si les qualia ont une
réalité et c'est important car admettre
leur réalité c'est remettre un pied dans
le dualisme pour montrer que les qualia
sont réels et représente bien quelque
chose en plus de la réalité physique
objectivement descriptible le philosophe
frank jackson a proposé l'expérience de
pensée suivante connu sous le
deux chambres de mari imaginons marly
une savante extrêmement intelligente
mais qu'on a enfermé toute sa vie dans
une pièce dans laquelle il n'y a que du
noir et du blanc bien en lui a mis des
lunettes qui convertissent tout en noir
et blanc alors marie est excellente en
physique en neurobiologie tout ce que
vous voulez l accès à toutes les
informations possibles et imaginables
sur la lumière la propagation la manière
dont elle est captée par l'oeil
analysées par le cerveau etc
imaginons mari arrivent à comprendre
tout ce qu'il est possible de comprendre
sur la perception des couleurs sur les
états cérébraux impliqués jusque dans le
détail de l'activation du moindre
neurones sauf qu'elle vit dans un monde
en noir et blanc
si un jour on décide finalement de
sortir mari de sa pièce en noir et blanc
et de lui montrer une rose rouge quelle
va être sa réaction
intuitivement on se dit que ça va lui
faire un choc un qu'elle va faire une
découverte la découverte de la sensation
de rouge du qualia rouge
elle va vraiment apprendre quelque chose
de nouveau en voyant cette rose rouge
même si elle avait pu anticiper calcul
est complètement l'état cérébrale dans
lequel elle se trouve en voyant cette
rose rouge
elle va vraiment apprendre quelque chose
de nouveau mais dans ce cas-là ça
signifie que même en connaissant dans
les moindres détails tout ce qu'il ya à
savoir des phénomènes physiques
biologiques cérébraux impliqués dans la
perception des couleurs
elle ne savait pas tout ce qu'il ya à
savoir sur la sensation de couleurs et
pour frank jackson cet argument tend à
montrer que notre conscience et
notamment l'existence d'equalia ne peut
pas complètement se réduire à des
phénomènes purement physiques et
matérielles et si l'expérience de pensée
vous paraît un peu tiré par les cheveux
en fait y'a pas besoin du tout d'une
pièce en noir et blanc pour la faire on
la ville presque quotidiennement avec
les odeurs quand vous sentez une
nouvelle odeurs que vous n'aviez jamais
expérimenté auparavant
on aurait bien pu tout vous expliquer
sur les molécules les récepteurs
olfactifs impliquer les zones cérébrales
activées
ça vous aurait pas aider à anticiper le
ressenti subjectif de cette odeur
dernière petite expérience de pensée
pour la route peux tu imaginer la chose
suivante une copie matériel de toi
parfaite un jumeau donc qui aurait
exactement la même constitution matériel
que toi mais dénué de toute expérience
consciente des nuées de quoi il ya donc
il perçoit et réagit à son environnement
exactement comme toi mais chez lui ça
n'est accompagnée d'aucune forme de
conscience
c'est ce qu'on appelle sans rire un
zombie philosophique du coup on parle
beaucoup de zombies en philosophie de
l'esprit tout à la verse des zombies de
films de zombies qui ont un comportement
assez caractéristique les zombies
philosophique
font rien de spécial dont jumeaux
zombies aurait exactement le même
comportement que toi ainsi par exemple
si en respirant une certaine odeur tu
dis non car l'odeur délicieuse ton
jumeaux zombies nuit dans les mêmes
conditions auraient le même comportement
d'hier et les mêmes mots sur le même ton
mais la différence c'est que chez toi ce
sera accompagné de l'expérience
consciente de l'odeur tandis que chez
lui bah non c'est un zombie ben non moi
je sais bien que tu parles zombies mais
ça fout de toi tu es un zombie ou bien
la femme est un zombie
en effet et même s'il te disais avec
conviction qu'elle n'en met pas un tu
devrais te méfier c'est exactement ce
que tirer un zombie mais ne plonge on
pas trop vite dans la paranoïa à la
question est surtout de savoir est ce
que cette hypothèse a seulement du sens
beaucoup de philosophes temps ne pas
penser que cette notion de zombies est
en fait absurde traiter l'information
avoir exactement le même comportement
qu'un être conscient c'est être
conscient et ici il est tout aussi
difficile d'argumenter dans un sens que
dans l'autre on tout cela vraiment à ce
qu'on appelle le problème difficile de
la conscience ce que met en lumière
toutes ces réflexions sur les qualia
qu'on adhère ou non à leur réalité c'est
qu'il y as et qu'il y aura toujours un
gouffre entre l'explication du
fonctionnement de quelques systèmes
physiques que ce soit et l'idée que ce
système physique produit une expérience
consciente et ce gouffre n'est pas du
même type que celui qui nous sépare
d'une pleine compréhension du
fonctionnement du cerveau par exemple ce
gouffre si tiens seulement à la
complexité biologique de l'objet étudié
tandis que le gouffre explicatif qui
nous sépare de la compréhension de la
conscience semble plus radicale en somme
la question d'où vient ma conscience
ressemble moins à une question technique
comme comment fonctionne mon cerveau cas
une question fondamentale comme d'où
vient la réalité c'est-à-dire une
question fascinante vertigineuse et
qu'on ne peut pas s'empêcher de se poser
mais à laquelle on devine qu absolument
aucune réponse ne peut être
satisfaisante
évidemment ne vous attendez pas à une
conclusion ferme et définitive sur ces
questions même si on l'a dit aujourd'hui
la plupart des philosophes de l'esprit
se reconnaissent dans le physique alisme
fonctionnaliste étoiles valeur thibault
je suis plutôt fonctionnaliste j'avoue
même si des expériences de pensée comme
celle de la foule de 100 milliards
d'êtres humains qui réalise la fonction
de mon cerveau me met mal à l'aise mais
je dirais que c'est justement dans cet
inconfort que réside une bonne part de
laval
de toutes ces réflexions si l'actualité
de ces débats vous intéresse les deux
principaux camps qui s'affrontent aux
yeux du grand public sont représentés
par david chalmers et daniel dennett des
nets c'est un physique à liszt pur et
dur qui pensent que la conscience va
finir par nous apparaître comme un
simple phénomène fonctionnel biologique
que les qualia sont juste une illusion
et qu'il n'y a pas de problème difficile
de l'autre côté on à david chalmers le
créateur et ardent défenseur de
l'argument des zombies celui qui a
popularisé le terme de problèmes
difficiles de la conscience et qui lui
est fermement convaincu que le physique
alisme rate quelque chose d'essentiel
et comme chalmers peut pas décemment
ressusciter le dualisme cartésien et
bien ils cherchent une solution radicale
au problème de la conscience par exemple
avec le psychisme
il s'agit d'une thèse qui postule que
tout élément de matière possède une
forme élémentaire de conscience et que
leur association en structures complexes
fini par produire des êtres conscients
complexe comme nous en sommes d'un côté
un père noël selon qui nous sommes tous
des zombies et de l'autre un serveur
selon qui chaque grain de sable a une
conscience et vous pensez que la
philosophie contemporaine et ennuyeuse
petit complément pour conclure si vous
êtes un ou une habituelle la chaîne vous
êtes peut être frustré qu'on ait si peu
parlé de science notant que le problème
de la conscience est justement
fréquemment abordés sous l'angle des
neurosciences la raison je l'évoqué au
tout début de la vidéo c'est que j'avais
surtout envie de parler de cette
question de la conscience phénoménal ce
problème difficile qui semble justement
échappé à l'analyse scientifique
classique
si vous voulez prolonger ces questions
je vous recommande d'aller voir la
dernière vidéo de monsieur fille qui
parle justement de ces différentes
facettes de la conscience la conscience
phénoménal dont on a parlé aujourd'hui
et la conscience d'accès qui est celle
dont parle plus traditionnellement les
neurosciences et ivo nous parle d'un
phénomène assez étonnant je vais essayer
de montrer qu'on peut voir avec son
cerveau sans voir avec sa conscience
merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo si vous
avez aimé surtout pourrez vous abonner à
la chaîne de monsieur fille parle pas
que de philosophie de l'esprit est ce
qui fait c'est vraiment super vous
pouvez aussi allé le soutenir sur tic
lit donc n'hésitez pas si vous les
accuse la chaîne de mon côté ça se passe
sur facebook et sur twitter et on se
retrouve très bientôt pour des nouvelles
villes
[Musique]